ah good to know you haven't got any
stronger since we broke up
how's a weak-ass punch oh let me check
yourself oh my god oh god that hurts so
bad why would you throw that at me wait
so why do you think Sara would just
trash her room and leave I don't know I
thought that we were getting along
unless she was kidnapped but who kidnap
her who wouldn't yeah I just realized
how creepy that sounded and I retract
that statement it does appear that there
were signs of a struggle
can we circle back to who would kidnap
Sahara I don't know like North Korea
Russia whoever kidnapped spies normally
these Sahara's a spy god damn let's be
cool
I gotta stop telling people that well
[ __ ] if she's kidnapped in the week out
a fighter or we could call the police
they could find her we use Find My
iPhone or the police aw quit being such
a Luke what yeah I'm not a wimp huh
you're a wimp oh please no why are you
selling your car there was a spider on
my steering wheel I am NOT a wimp Hecker
phone do what now how are you did oh wow
movies don't like it really takes no
time at all the hack somebody's fault
I know right it's crazy okay turning on
my my iPhone now but why kidnap me
because you're are you kidding me no one
took her phone Susan
glad you are all useless especially you
flat I got a hit let's go oh you you
good you're just mad I dumped you aren't
you Wow Wow here we go
classic Sahara I'm making everything
about her then why am I here Zoey
because you're an asset to the US
government and that makes you an asset
to me why what do you want the
government I'm sorry do you think that
this is a Bond film and I'm gonna tell
you my evil plan in a giant monologue
while your partner bursts through the
door to save you god damn it Vlad I
brought lemonade in case anyone was
parched okay this is a bad idea I'm
definitely calling the cops
I thought you weren't a wimp there's a
difference between being brave indeed
stupid not that much of a difference
Leroy Jenkins nah can save you yeah but
like let's hurry up and save her because
I don't know what that's not say we did
Jesus Zoey did you get your 1-1 nineties
book of cliches shut up come any closer
and I'll slice this dorky girl's neck
nice
Wow
that is one week
Oh
okay they said were free to go
good I just want to go home and lay on
the couch and never leave the house
again but I guess that makes me a wimp
so are you kidding you're wimping has
saved us when you pass out and claps
their arms I left her confused and
vulnerable so that I can deliver the
final blow
like a boss definitely tag-teamed her
you did you kill the dude imma win oh oh
yeah wimpiest wait okay stop yelling
yeah yes let's get ice creams and lots
of ice cream and I'm so hungry
[Music]
Wow